well rent is also rising a new report
from rent.com shows prices in our area
of 28 percent from a year ago joe mohler
live in one of the least affordable
areas according to that report joe
hey there we are in symphony park this
area is right near the smith center
these are brand new apartments take a
look it is a pretty nice area and
according to that report symphony park
here is one of the most expensive areas
to rent in we also stopped by one of the
most affordable areas in the valley as
well
a new report by rent.com breaks down
area affordability it shows 67 percent
of rentals in the valley are costing
more than 2 thousand dollars a month
this new area of downtown called
symphony park according to the report is
one of the most expensive areas a one
bedroom is more than eighteen hundred
dollars get a two or three bedroom and
you'll pay much more todd henderson says
he pays around three thousand dollars
here the hunt ridge and orleans square
area of charleston and maryland parkway
is listed as one of the most affordable
areas a studio or one bedroom around
eight hundred dollars marco schalla says
his rent just went up a hundred bucks to
eight fifty he says it is still the
cheapest i
try but
this is the cheapest one right now
everybody else is over a thousand dollar
rent
you know so it's for me right now it's a
little higher but
i
can still afford it
a big problem is a lack of rentals on
the market according to the nevada
apartment association right now there
are about 9 400 available apartments for
rent at a normal time they say around 11
000 is about normal to have on the
market at any given time reporting live
in symphony park john muller live local
now
thank you very much joe let's break down
the other rental trends in our area this
is a look at some of the prices people
are paying across the valley all right
toward the lower end as we talk about
we've got about 800 for a one bedroom in
the west las vegas area and that's
trending there for about a month now in
the middle range we go more to this area
here centennial hills their renters are
paying about fourteen hundred dollars a
month and one of the top prices people
are paying no surprise here would be
summerlin area their one bedroom going
for about eight eighteen hundred a month
but overall for up to two bedroom across
the las vegas area which is about 67
percent of people they're paying more
than two thousand dollars a month
christian